this mill dates from for more than seven
hundred years our paper has been used
for printing the
french constitution of the big names using our
paper i think of dali picasso
chagall making paper requires a
certain nuland here time stands still
peaks  story
[Music]
[Applause]
hello my name is emmanuel and
welcome to the richard de bas paper mill
there are only two or three mills left
throughout france so my
grandfather bought a mill during the
second world war
this mill became  a
family story since it's been three
generations
a paper machine today is
capable of producing 1000 tons of
paper per day we produce about
2 tons of paper per year one sheet or
minimum it takes three weeks to a
month if  we want paper to be two
qualities we have to take the time
to do things well
[Music]
hello I'm michèle so the
paper from the mill richard de bas l  the
first step is to make the
paper pulp yesterday
we got the recovery cloth in the water and we get
the dough
[Music]
2nd step is to make the sheet of
paper
you have to do the works to make the
sheet
third stage to recover
the pressing operation we crush the door, that is to
say the sheets of paper inserted
undone to remove the water
fourth stage this will be the lifting operation
5th stage we come to the drying racks
to hang the sheets  on the
ropes so that they dry
naturally all the operations are
done by hand that you will never have
two identical faults
there I will present to you our
floral inclusion paper we notice the
inclusions of natural flowers that have
grown in our gardens the blue and
blue ones  and red in summer we will welcome
our fresh petals every morning in the gardens
which will be incorporated
directly into the paper pulp I
think it is quite important to
want to  ir preserving this tradition of
making paper by hand it is
very rewarding to know that our
paper is used for very beautiful things
yes
[Music]